what makes a great superhero movie it's
the million dollar question in Hollywood
right now or more accurately six billion
with Marvel creating what is now the
most successful film franchise in film
history based solely on superheroes
after decades of this superhero craze
we've essentially seen every possible
iterations or versions of the genre some
are excellent pushing boundaries and
attempting to redefine the genre while
others well marvel and DC movies can be
fun and enjoyable but there's one film
that really exemplifies a great
superhero movie let's call all the way
back to 1999 the year which housed key
to release their cyberpunk masterpiece
The Matrix despite its heavy sci-fi
undertones The Matrix at its core is a
superhero movie I mean look at it an
unlikely hero develops unique powers to
protect the world from evil now add an
iconic look a few memorable set pieces
and this that's right
Marvel and DC have the matrix to thank
for this iconic three point hero landing
that has become the staple of the genre
put all of this together and you've got
the classic formula for a superhero film
but what makes the matrix shine is in
its narrative structure specifically the
journey that Keanu Reeves character
Thomas Anderson goes through to become
Neel the chosen one to better understand
this let's take a look at a narrative
structure called the hero's journey by
Joseph Campbell Campbell believed that
every piece of fiction regarding a hero
goes through a very specific set of
stages 17 to be precise later
screenwriter Christopher Vogler would
simplify these 17 stages down to 12
these stages then can be broken into
three distinct acts
departure initiation and return every
film about a hero follows this distinct
pattern the hero sets on a journey faces
a series of challenges and then returns
home after a triumphant victory most
superhero blockbusters focus on this
second act the initiation often
characterized by these big final boss
BOTS
it's what also makes these films so
entertaining to watch as everything
builds up to one final climactic battle
the Vogler names the ordeal where our
hero faces the most difficult challenge
yet but what happens afterwards is this
part of the movie as memorable to you
probably not which is a shame because
this final act the return is perhaps the
most important part of any hero's
journey and this is where the matrix
truly shines let's step back and look at
the ordeal it occurs in the matrix when
neo and Trinity set out on an impossible
mission to rescue Morpheus from the
clutches of the evil agents our heroes
are successful and for a second it seems
as though things are starting to wrap up
but that's not quite what happens here
as they return to the real world one by
one they are compromised
neo is left to face the agents alone for
the first time
what the hell this stage is referred to
as the road back by Vogler where the
hero begins to deal with the
consequences of confronting the dark
forces of the ordeal and is pursued by
the vengeful forces he has disturbed
that's exactly what happens a chase
between neo and the agents as he
searches for a way back neo is
eventually cornered and then something
truly unique happens this scene came as
a shock to a lot of the people watching
the matrix for the first time and it's a
shock that is well deserved by the
Wachowskis the film is riddled with
uncertainties about whether Thomas is
truly neo the prophesized chosen one at
one point we even hear that he isn't
from the Prophet herself you already
know what I'm going to tell Iran ik Lee
and symbolically the person who has the
most trouble believing is none other
than Thomas himself this is beautifully
visualized when neo fails to make a
seemingly impossible jump a metaphorical
leap of faith you have to let it all go
neo fear doubt disbelief free that's why
perhaps the best cinematic moment in The
Matrix happens in this scene
mr. Anders
run run
[Music]
how do you visualize faith to the
Wachowskis that answer is choice upon
further viewing it's surprising to see
just how many times choices are
visualized throughout the film but it
asks the same question every time do you
choose to escape and avoid the harsh
reality of truth or do you choose to
confront and believe it when all odds
are against Thomas he chooses to believe
in himself what is he doing he's
beginning to believe that's why we
witness a transformation a moment in
which a simple man becomes a hero and
when our faith for the hero is finally
proven right it feels well-deserved this
stage by the way is actually called
resurrection where the hero is purified
and transformed through the most
dangerous meeting with death perhaps
this is where a lot of superhero films
today fall short
most of them choose to follow a safe
proven formula that neither raises the
stakes nor truly tests our hero we're
supposed to simply accept them as heroes
without knowing why it is that they
deserve it it makes for an easy viewing
but also a highly predictable one there
are of course a few exceptions most
notably in films like The Dark Knight or
recently Black Panther but it seems that
many still fail to understand why it is
that we love superheroes so much as much
as we love watching our heroes fight and
win it's the side of them that makes
them human their vulnerability but still
the willingness to fight against all
odds that keeps us coming back because
it's only after moments like these after
a truly harrowing journey the real hero
is born
you